- Le statu quo n'est pas
acceptable, estime le directeur
national de santé publiqueLuc B.
La Fonderie Horne de
Rouyn-Noranda doit réduire
ses émissions d'arsenic
le plus rapidement possible.
Dr LUC BOILEAU, dir. national
de santé publique du Québec
- Soyons très clairs, en ce
moment. Pour moi, le maintien
des émissions d'arsenic
au niveau actuel,
ce n'est pas tolérable,
considérant les impacts
sur la santé qui sont connus.
- Il ne s'avance toutefois pas
exigences qui doivent
être imposées à la Fonderie
Horne. Une déception pour
plusieurs citoyens et médecins,
qui réclament l'imposition
de la node la node la node la ne
3 nanogrammes par mètre cube
d'arsenic dans l'air.
- On aurait aimé ça qu'il
se prononce plus fermement,
avec des chiffres clairs.
On aurait souhaité le
3 nanogrectivement,
pour l'arsenic. On aurait voulu
aussi des chiffres pour
les autres métaux lourds,
les autres contaminants aussi.
- On a a d'autres
contaminants et on n'a pas
regardé non plus la synergie
entre les contaminants.
Parce que ce n'est pas 1 plus 1
qui fait 2, c'est 1 plus 1
qui fait peut-être 5.
- Ce qu'on entend beaucoup,
c'est : Qu'est-ce qui est
acceptable comme norme pour
les gens de Rouyn? Puis moi,
mon questionnement, c'est :
Pourquoi est-ce que quelque
chose d'autre que la norme
serait acceptable pour
les gens de Rouyn?
- La Santé publique prévoit
faire d'autres études et
réclamer d'autres avis d'experts
dans les prochaines semaines.
Un délai qui n'es
nécessaire, croit la députée
solidaire de Rouyn-Noranda-
Témiscamingue.
Tous les yeux sonnt
tournés vers Glencore,
propriétaire de la Fonderie
Horne.
La multinationale estime
qu'elle devra investir près
d'un demi milliard de dollars
dans ses installations pour
réduire ses émissions.
Le chef des opérations cuivre
Amérique du Nord Claude
Bélanger, qui s'exprimait
pour la première fois dans
le dossier, admet que
l'entreprise devra être
plus transparente.
- C'est clair qu'avec la station
qu'on voit on ne communique pas
avec une fréquence acceptable
aux citoyens. Les soignants
beaucoup de section et non pas
semaine, on se met en mouvement.
On va communiquer de manière
plus fréquente. Jean est en
mesure de voir l'avancement du
projet.
- Tout ça arrive au moment où la
compagnie négocie avec Québec
pour obtenir une aide financière
pour mod